good evening everybody
welcome to Development Committee trijet
September 2013 I'll stop there are
emergency evacuation announcement should
we be required to evacuate building
would you please leave the building by
the nearest available exit to the
chamber our assembly point will be in
the public car park at the side specific
suite please do not delay your
evacuation to collect any belongings
please do not return into the dome in
until permission is given to do so by
caps or staff please note the meeting
will be recorded first possibly not that
well because only front bench
microphones working so that's what we
remember to speak clearly to power
behind your voice if possible please
so apologies for absence we don't have
any at the moment we have no substitute
members who have no it's lapooh house
the mountain does not remembers
attending minutes of the meeting home on
the 11th of September 2018 you happy for
me to sign those as the correct me Rep
over that meeting region thank you
declarations of interest
councillor Williams
item 7 is another kidney as I am the
parish thank you
right we'll move on to item six lamb to
the rear of 12 to 22 this image
supermarket the site then is an
irregular shape it sort of follows this
boundary where the Castle Road car park
and comes down to the south and skirts
found an existing cluttered block here
in here braless is found in Mount Hermon
and incorporates these buildings here so
all of these detached in just still
tight units mostly single story would be
demolished as part of the proposal and
take to the vocational this red line
shows instead demolished and the sellers
an existing supermarket adjacent area
compact Castle Road car park around this
edge and largely residential development
to the south this flatter block here is
two-story and there is a small bungalow
also adjacent to part of the boundary
and this building adjacent to these
boundary is a commercial office unit
then take you to the proposal a note
at the site the access point would be in
approximately same position and ask the
existing access point to decide which
one is too small acts of choice the site
at the moment that they were in around
that position access with them one
centrally through and the larger block a
and which we standard around the
northern boundary immunity space will be
provided to the flatted blocks in this
area here and then in this area here and
also sort of more smaller landscapes
along the northern boundary in addition
to the communal spaces when I bring the
elevations obviously the balconies are
provided to the flats Islam the last
baby so we had a skinful excites first
put forward in 2013 it was for a very
different layout and that was refused on
the grounds of the layout amongst other
things the applicants have gone away and
now the entrance is more attractive
now Destry on points of access to the
customers car park which would be a
benefit in terms of into the site which
could be in the castle go to our
balconies adjoining and would also
provide another point of access for
people living on the site to access the
western end of the high street and take
to the animations so this these are the
elevations of the larger I'm flattered
got a these so these two elevations here
would be as viewed from the most
expensive car there is an increase in
lung level so at the basis in this
because in vendors warm and then views
from the Castle Road car park is this
one here and you can move along on the
bar at the bottom please night
a bit more of that plan and then this is
the other motivation to the castle moat
can't up what the applicant is trying to
do is ensure that because this scientist
that's seen essentially from 360 degrees
there's no memory of elevation and there
isn't in the sort of public domain or
seem like immediately adjoining
residential properties they have tried
to provide interest to every elevation
so there's no knowledge like elevations
got lots of fenestration and interest
and staggered and articulation of the
building and until you to block the
operations please so this is the smaller
block and what the applicants is trying
to do here is impress the fact that part
of this block is quite close to evaluate
that some envelope number 14 and so they
bring the the height substantially down
from from what other heights that the
buildings would be this is the only
elevation that is sort of blank with no
interest and that is immediately
adjacent to the block which has offices
within it until you to the sections so
this is the section through the site
showing the bungalow joining and this
would be the road through the site so
this is one elevation of being a smaller
block and this is a section through not
a and then this is the elevation when
this property here has a boundary or
runs eastward Road to turn off these odd
rows come up through the sites and
you've seen
police in in height of the London levels
so this is a smaller block being a
monastic sort of a road frontage and
then you've got that residential
bungalow set behind and that's here with
a sloping down with that roof I'll take
you to some photos at the site showing
the existing buildings on the site so
this is peace Wood Road here coming up
the existing access which has double
yellow lines on it to its entirety and
then there's two access points to the
site the new access would be an
approximately this location to see there
are a number of different use on the
site at present this is a flooring
warehouse there's a two-story but as the
most is his single story on the site
this is within the site looking towards
Britain called
produces one of their flattened blocks
adjacent not two-story building and then
again some of the buildings that not the
entirety the site faster it's not
particularly good surface uses car
parking to the various uses that go on
huh this is one of the building
single-story and used to begin present
and then this is from the most expensive
car park Jason to the sites that have
seen this the Romans rendered wall and
so part of the larger block rock being
so Bank would be in approximately this
position and skirting band that boundary
this is the three-story office got this
adjacent part of the smaller properties
behind that take you back to layout or
to just take you through some of the key
points and the proposal would result in
the loss of employment use the site the
existing buildings are in use for a
number of different purposes including
some retail is a local tuition use a
dance studio a physiotherapy clinic
health and fitness studio and Theater
Arts Center the scientific within the
designated town center boundary and
policies in the radioactive plant duty
to support and enhance Roerig local
business this must be waged against
however other considerations the site is
not identified as part of the primary or
secondary shopping fronted by a town
center and it is more than the interface
between a commercial core of the town
center the residential areas that are
closest onto the site but the price
residential use would contribute to
housing supply in the district in
sustainable location we've already
accessed to shops syllabus and a
transport we say in residential you also
state competent in relation to the
residential uses and
employment once the key considerations
in this occupation is affordable housing
provision and this application was
proposed to be before you earlier in the
year the recommendation for reviews or
because the applicant was offering no
affordable housing contribution at all
and in the applicants in the course of
the application submitted a viability
appraisal we have had that independently
attested by DVS a branch of the
valuation office and they have concluded
now that three units or dividable or
this scene say now it's anticipated that
they aren't maximizes the use of the
unusual site and state early on at all
on the site community 2014 application
the layout was different and this block
extended over the boundary sorry not not
over the boundary but it came across
more than the boundary to that garden
now they step that and further east so
actually the mayor boundary joins a car
park what I will recommend tonight is
actually
parking spaces would enable some great
provision for soft landscaping a bit
more to buffer so I would recommend that
we additional condition on and to
require the lots of warm space that
would still provide one space per flat
in this site it would just result in the
most important one visitor space which
obviously would be in demand across the
whole site so I don't think the lot of
it would be problem given especially the
car parking area that surrounds man
should note that they have been one
additional consultation response
received from the motives of 56 okie
Avenue that concerns the extra
developments and the impacts on
infrastructure an additional condition
is also recommended to require three
percent of the trainees to meet you in
building regulation requirement related
to wheelchair accessibility to comply
with focus in eight states the condition
is also recommended to require details
of the bit enclosures that I mentioned
previously I would also recommend that a
slightly wording of condition 12 to
require we say your face and that can be
provided on the sites and all the car
parking spaces can be completely minimum
requirement 2.5 lights are meters and I
recommend us incorporated into condition
12 the recommendation they notice is one
of approval subject to the condition
state is under the reports the condition
updates I've mentioned verbally and the
section 106 agreement requiring a
provision of 344 units on the site and
he counts the hoc way when you arrive
with only about 20 to 30 seconds in and
we'd only covered the location of the
site so on this occasion I do think
you've had a majority so we have
capability can I just check what you
have been
debate on this item on our right speaker
this evening mr. Hills that touch the
microphone five minutes I'll let you
know when you're gone on for sit down I
don't wish that too much what's already
known for doing the objections that we
not I'm mainly here to point out that
this aggregation does affect 14 Philip
drastically don't believe I've seen the
effect
why 92 year old grandmother resides here
and I know for being there and it's
about in the garden of surveying it then
photos don't show it from the garden it
will cause severe privacy and security
issues for her so the main point is
young and I can something that was
saying that in the rear garden the
living room and the dining room
reporting things will be done directly
on route by line-of-sight and people are
looking out there first second and third
floor windows and balconies of doc I I
don't think that portrayed
we also gather up a block B that was
shown on there my opinion it's not
direct that we're looking but it still
does a look it's been moved
I think the difference it's been moved
over to the east side there were still a
third floor balcony but would look
directly into the garden and into
private prices my concern is that in the
report
and just being spoken there is that
there was no mention at all that there
was direct overlooking from a blog a
larger block and by actually moving
Block B to the east it exposes the Torah
larger block a which is on a high level
that was actually shown on
[Music]
next why is that in the previous
officer's report painted the 22nd of
March for the previous meeting that was
withdrawn on the material panel in
consideration there was points five
point four six with five point five one
there might be the note this one
specifically referred to fourteen finish
building that police report and that's
in the report the first that they order
the updated version it doesn't it's not
so specific on the recommendations for
finish and there was mentioned at the
screening that that's been proposed my
big bear with this is that these this is
the full application in four years and
the other pin is that four years and the
fortifications will satisfy the
screening of fourteen Finch girls why
does it have to be done after it might
be approved why can't it be approved the
screening decided before that
that's the last part I compensate the
last part in the last point is just
simply mentions about the party don't
believe one parking space per flat meets
the policy there isn't place there is
mentioned that if there were two parking
spaces per premises there is mention if
the error is in good school alternative
form of transport or that can be way of
it if you liked however the reality is
is the two-bedroom properties there are
going to be more than one kind which for
each party or my opinion a bit pace in
the future as well and
lastly in terms of the buffering I would
like future if it gets approved any
future buffering that's directly affects
the back of my dad's property I would
like consultation in the process to
decide how that's buffer at how that
screen because ultimately the big trees
remembers that's the whole unit under
startup no thank you
I think this one development which was
what I very slightly too big yet again
when they pertain to them to the
extremes and it ends up in certain
development you know the boundary layer
and I just like to draw attention to
technical issues from what way my
plaintiff winter view which is one again
I do pt I'm not a member of this
committee today but read I cannot see so
if you would like to do anything solid
in please don't use bread would you kind
of line to read it looks like that quite
often they call it
maybe I'll talk about parking beside it
I'm aware this is a main urban area not
if you can be described in traffic must
be revived it may not narrator where
parking standards may be relaxed that's
not what great come on possibly wouldn't
only have a problem with interweb spaces
however the reissue starts when we
through positive the set the parking the
sizes
yes two point five by five inches is the
minimum standard the standard actually
is two point nine by 525 meters and that
is what the standard says should be made
available on any site the minimum base
ice two point five by five should only
be used in exceptional circumstances as
I see it the exceptional circles that is
here is fitting some landscaping I'm not
sure that's exception I think the
landscaping should going into parking
sizes I don't I don't think one should
happen without the other I think this is
probably a demonstration the site is
probably trying to squeeze too much in
into it and I think there's no reason
why the parking size is currently the
standard a two point one both I know
that's really cool too far it doesn't
send a lot but I think it's very
we transpose Carlson's to spaces we
still not fitting true
that's the parking side of it I think
that should members are aware of that
also on Harvey standard cycle storage
I'm aware of these conditioned in
condition 13 specific on the condition
because the standard says one cycle
parking area curve reading which must be
covered in secured is that of
institutions it doesn't can we say in
accordance with our policy for instance
so that it's clear that that would be
mate I'm not happy with the affordable
housing but I just like some
confirmation or thing sodium session
basic set of terms would bring back a
bit more closely defined to say that the
the only these three they multiplied in
which appears that that's but we have to
go in these are two bedroom and are the
same as the other facts in the scheme
that up differentiation in any way so
that the tenure is blowing their bedroom
flats within the scheme
yeah I think I just relate that clear
isn't the way it's been off they're not
even quite getting back from the bit
under foot bed and that kind of in that
case by this recent emphasize the point
they should be the same dick should
continue lying
from the debate up to members now I
think for clarity we speak to the
recommendation for approval in the first
instance just to clarify three present
three variations two conditions one is
about the loss of one parking space to
landscaping I don't know what parking
space number it was but yeah the second
one is enclosure of bin stores and then
the third variation was to condition 12
for three disabled Bay's so first we
have master breaking I've got three
questions one is will of light then fit
into the reduced size parking spaces in
the past there's been questions asked
about the access road that runs
alongside the comes in between the two
commercial properties I'm not sure what
the ownership status is of that road
someone let's put the double yellow
lines have been put down have been put
down by a company or a private
individual not by Essex highways Emily
and thirdly could we have some more
detail about the screening for sporting
event field it seems a bit vague thank
you that's all they're my three question
okay I just covered the entrance first
the entrance that you've mentioned it's
not within the site of the application
and it's for the the applicants to
resolve the access issue outside of the
planning application on this matter the
other two questions will come to one
we've got a long line concept oh yeah
thank you
I hope questions to us but depends on
what the answers are uh still with the
questions the car park I wanted to
clarify on the part on the plan there
that's pointed down in the middle which
is closest to Britain court if now be
further out that that's it don't point
that what is the distance between the
parking just a little bit further over
what that's it that'd be there what is
the distance between those parking
spaces and the houses in Britain course
so that distance there yeah who's the
nearest point because when you look at
the documents it looks very narrow okay
depends on what
if you got to the access through to the
carpark got some queries on that we're
really is that going to become a public
right away is that going to be
controlled by goats which only the
residents have accessed through because
that's going to very quickly become a
shortcut from the car park through
tomorrow spaces so I think defense to
the resident potential residents there I
think that should be have some sort of
control date with regard up 14 yes I'm
still a little unclear on the screen in
there the speaker spoke to her about
having being a legislative be in
consultation with him I'm not sure that
we can do that record doing that but
what I would suggest is that he's done
with consultation to the port councils
them directly in the eyes with the
that's quite close so on that boundary
of the park what will be put in place
there to mitigate any noise coming
through from there of Park cars any
doors etc will there be for example will
landscaping acoustic clean see what will
be put along there to that is quite
close to those buildings for meters it's
not that far there is a condition that
requires boundary must be agreed
non-price including the name and so
you'd expect the summer new sort of
fence boundary there isn't space to
accommodate non-stop landscaping on that
plan between that parking space and
sort of amenity space to those to us but
there would be some sort of thanks for
Brendan to try and if you think that's
what I think
what I would like to do is to include
that to be in consultation with the ward
councillors as with the park for number
42 the directed access to the campus at
the moment there is we've shown this
plan as being the potential for an
access point through it has benefits in
terms of the fact that the missus
carvaka Jason which is a public car park
visitors to this site could easily park
that and go visit my friends or
relatives and if there's an access point
there ideal
I expect you know your point that if
there was public access through there
which I didn't don't think we're in
visiting and it would potentially create
a point for people to park him go
through this essentially which is a
residential area and and car park and if
you like a shared service road so the
applicant would have to approach the
council I'm given a discount of car park
to a green music putting an access point
through I think that because of this
existing fence along that boundary but
as part of the discharge of condition
related to the amount of treatments we
could require them to put in an access
points which were stated and that only
the residents had access to so to enable
residents to open and have control over
that point but not the general public
Jeremy come back on that I would like to
propose that that as a condition that's
put on but it has to be a controlled
access and it's done by licensed with
the district care
I don't think that took looking too much
of an issue then that way that mitigates
establishing any public right of way
thank you
sorry on that I probably suggest that we
just clarify the condition regarding
landscaping to say we would like them to
put in a point ease of access but only
for residents
it has to be control minute but just
only on the question of the parking
sizes I think we've seen planning
applications in the past in town center
locations that have been able to
demonstrate that they don't need any
parking spaces because of the proximity
for the car parks bus routes and so on
this application falls into that
category I think that the number of
spaces we've got is relatively generous
considering the town center location and
I take the quoting that can't slow
griffin is made about the parking sizes
and councillor horn but I feel that if
we say we want biggest races all will
end up with is less spaces and I don't
know which is best bigger spaces but
that's not one more smaller spaces and
more of them I think it's a difficult
challenge that we we have oh yeah yeah
in this residential setting the space is
alight the allocation to each flat so
you know track number 20 has parking
space 20 people tend to stick with that
and so it's not a situation we've got
lots of different cars coming going out
different spaces a lot especially people
God's work on they underneath the
community today and probably in that
situation these minimum parking bay size
is appropriate where it's maybe in a
supermarket car park that's one thing I
keep their game lots of things to
improve all the the largest space
may be deemed more appropriate that we
have had an appeal decision as well
relating to the minimum and maximum
parking both sizes it didn't go in our
favor with inspector taking the view
that far 2.5 Wi-Fi if it's declared as a
minimum is acceptable it's a parking
bays ice there might be a preferred
option where a site could provide that
or on this site we are looking at a fair
you constrain sites already the
economics of it are such that we are
only getting three inaudible dwellings
and I think I view is this the two point
five by five is appropriate given the
need to balance all those competing
amenity space matters
can you stop talking I know there's been
much discussion about powerful size and
spices I have a question that has
exactly the same size there's no
variation so what I looked at was
whether they can fit in through your say
evil face and they can with all the
other faces being two point five by five
the disabled Bay's require an additional
light meter to the side or anything to
one additional needs to look like to the
rear and they could accommodate those
within the layout so that was an
additional or condition I just want to
amend that condition society just to
clarify that and really expect three of
those to be the disable based on all the
rest of achievement like the high
I haven't seen it specifically stated
our apartment is going to be allocated
to flat numbers these X's that does that
mean tension but is my sunshine fit so
that is not yes that's not what they
told us but that's what I would expect
if you are buying a flat generally you
lose one space per flat on that
development
you probably I would have thought the
developer would look to sell a flat with
a parking space allocated to it well as
I sense that though it's not you know
wouldn't be by condition that we're
requiring that at moments and condition
relation they were because although the
building is not directly behind that
property the balconies are looking out
we've still got an issue and overlooking
using their balconies actually there or
overlooking property near causing issues
with the realtor and the other thing is
that as we pointed out that block I is
they've about police a community so
potentially be overlooking that property
as well especially if the ography of the
lamed Rosie's yeah away from that
property so it's actually there's even
exaggerated in waters they do things I
doubt so there are various issues
they're doing with amenity overlooking
that may well be potentially that we've
been through stick barrier boundary and
green breathe deep which which needs to
be
there needs to be much more detail about
that to make sure that that issue is
okay I'm just going to step in the
outliner hopefully below but I'm not a
witch face it's the motivator so yeah
that animation that faces this is the
rear boundary in a rare garden area
number forty has balconies on it at
first and second floor and they're about
you've got about 34 meters from the
rebound you here to that elevation that
the land does why not
so they are elevated so there will be a
degree of overlooking from these
balconies into living in around this
area here and then on this smaller block
their balconies on this and nothing on
this elevation facing south but facing
west their balconies not in this part
immediately adjacent foot William
emotions
yep so if you're looking at this so
that's that's from the back so you've
got these impulse windows here but
nothing that would provide you know
promote direct overlooking from it from
there
south-facing he and that's West facing
and these will windows so they're
windows you couldn't step out from its
this base here which you could step out
from and then if you like the view would
be back to number fourteen that way but
I guess there is a balance between being
a town center location where there is a
level of a sort of overlooking that
comes from living in what own
environment and being overlooked and
that is also in terms of the boundary
treatment that could happen here if you
wanted to prevent any possibility of
anybody see inside the garden the
boundary would have to be significant so
what I would suggest is get rid of the
parking space immediately adjacent that
boundary I'm putting in sand please that
what they don't spread a lot can maybe
gain some height to provide some degree
if I'm screening sort of those stock
minister I just wanted to
but you've demonstrated but I just like
to ask that once they will be busy
showing them piecing it okay to show how
much profit at the moment is that the
recommendation is you have section 106
require the development of write three
four units on the site and even terms of
the actual section 106 agreement that
will be quite that in a very brief
summary of what so to be in that little
agreement and all that only your team
will work and I have such a standard
template there are causes that you can
put in in terms of Bob left clause so
potentially we can look at something
like that it's not specifically that
they have to I don't think demonstrates
how much they've sold their properties
for us then keep the development
that's like a tax on nonprofits I think
the word for this has been done already
through the independent valuation of the
DBS DCs I think what we can do is though
it will come up difficult so that way
certain if things change in the market
or things happened that we are certain
that the three units is the maximum that
they can provide so I think we could
work with our legal team to make sure
that we are getting as much if you like
as possible that we can do from this
developments and so we'll pull that work
into the legal agreements make sure it's
followed on from points of counsel which
is that as I understand it as I recall
where the milk is going to be doing
that's actually quite high ground so do
you know what height differentials
between that block and you mentioned
about losing the
car parking space the bottom and if we
look straight along the road coming on
up to the rock then you've got the trees
any screen that's popping onto the car
parking space won't actually into the
because of the height increase it is not
here yeah yes so I mean there will be
some planting along here and the reason
I think I wanted to see this more
landscaping here in fact at least a tree
planting here is more to do this
elevation here I think just to shield it
so not only the potential for I overlook
even the balcony there's some windows
there it is an impression of overlooking
that you get as well as actually as I
perceive so I think if they were just
some sort of green that has some height
there it would help in my view with the
relationship between this slot and this
of glow here but yes the highest
difference is socialist you know a tree
it's something to share the potential
for all overlooking from there we do my
34 meter separation you can research
that might that might help
so looking at this section through here
so that's the side elevation that the
office would be on for the smaller block
then you're looking at balconies to this
front elevation facing slowly facing
sounds so potential for overlooking
there so that the difference in line
levels is not perhaps as excessive here
but there are quite a lot of differences
say from the you are offenders car park
there's quite an increase in height so
that there are differences and nonmetals
on the site and surrounding but we're
not perhaps so marked between and there
[Music]
on the diagram shows the road goes up to
the boundary age I would suggest that
and be taken back in relation to his
marking space so that that becomes part
of the green boundary
you just mark the parking space the same
be removing yeah if the road finished at
the edge of additional green yeah it's
saying yeah the small space so why I'm
suggesting and I mentioned the parking
space yeah because there's also so yeah
we'll have to pay parking charges the
park their resume they want any
concessions for them
no members without recommendations
printed from six point one through six
foot four it was three variations I
mentioned at the beginning to blossom
parking space and closing every hit the
store in the creation of disabled bodies
there are three more items the detail of
condition for adding in consultation
with ward councillors the moment council
Steptoe about the control and gate
access through suitable agreement with
our DC and then the the allocation the
numbered allocation over the plaques of
the park umbrellas
so condition for is about the
landscaping landscaping in consultation
with okay yeah it goes the block nothing
I mentioned which is just that we're
going to condition and three four flats
be built the building regulations for
accessibility everyone absolutely clear
okay those members of paper of the
recommendation for approval please
indicate
those games that item is terrible our
next item in this 1 to 5
South End Road Rochford 2 applications
about being at Red Lion unfortunately to
come in of is giving a different clarity
of blindness red and blue Lions have
special meaning I mean look the bloomin
Lions are men so the areas of land that
the applicant troubles that aren't
anything to do with these applications
so like adjoining land video may go to
give himself traded using access
easements across red lines in planning
thought must define the site so I take
the point at disadvantages some members
and I don't think the authors of the
legislation thought that one out
but if members were expecting as a
result of the comments tonight that we
come back with a preferable color
unfortunately we can't oblige because
the applicants were makes it means that
they will define a red line they are
required to by regulation so I can't
help you
and I think we need to just focus on the
planning applications tonight we'll find
another venue for the d7 description of
that and sorting out resolutely because
obviously everyone needs to be able to
interpret but the colors in each beauty
colors well sorry cherry everybody the
point of disability discrimination just
come on quite possibly but not not for
resolving tonight unfortunately
Thank You Sharon this application is to
assign one to five south in road it's a
breaker shops between Lester Avenue in
Queen Elizabeth chase the development
Mullen parks just over here on the
airport the ambling just just off the
map to the north and you'll see that
there is a pedestrian alleyway actually
been blocked off in parts behind the
buildings it's not a vehicle access
it's a service access for beans and the
like if we can jump to the first photo
please this should give there you go
this is the lesser Avenue and Queen
Elizabeth chase that ain't a unit we're
gonna see in a minute is up here your
suits up so that he proved quite vibrant
we say there's a lay-by worth noting to
the front of the premises and jumps a
second one please concerns us tonight is
this second lining from the far end at
Queen Elizabeth
which is here it's this unit here with a
blue moon frontage members probably
can't quite see on these photos but I
can tell you that the flats above are
served by front doors alongside the the
shop entrances which is young quite
unusual sometimes we find it on the back
or perhaps through the shop which
initiated stress in your policy but
we're lucky in these case that these
have the number 125 ie has a door
alongside the shop instance number one
to five the shop was previously a
computer shop which actually moved next
door in the scheme of things creating
this vacancy it was some some two years
ago the floor plan that he's
predominantly opened we found them that
and the application of course of your
secret there is retrospective policy TM
36 to your development management plan
seeks to retain enhance village and
maintenance shops such as these to
ensure that day to day needs population
a certain sort on the location and it's
next to 18th amendment quite essentially
residential area preamble to that policy
recognizes that on retail uses such as
this this is what we call Tsui generous
its outside of any other use classes
that's what the lighting turn millions
they like the barbarian drug be taken
there not anyone specific that made up
with different ones so sewage is not a
class in itself it's outside of the
penny controls is that's why in these
Planning Commission and the preambles
also recognizes that such users like
this this is a tattooist it can perform
a function to serve adjoining area but
if we jump on them
sorry yes s okay the policy though does
require that before the shop is lost
that the applicant demonstrates in the
council and then the decision that you
have to make that there's been
sufficient attempts to try and save it
for retail purposes to let it to
advertise it get retail interest started
when the computer shop shop Shipley now
that wasn't done I think the computer
shop moved and the testing guy came in
he was a result about reports went to
some colleagues acquire ease and we have
the application with us today so you'll
see the recommendation before you is one
of refusal because we hadn't been able
to be proven that that sub shop would
have had retail potential that was worth
any London so and so the recommendation
Chairman is refusal for the reasons set
out in the report that's the mountain
packages just very quickly
Jim thank you the young it's not
shopping planning law that's why I'm
able to point back in sir generous i
mean especially compared to a
hairdressers but rightly or wrongly in
the nineteen fifties hairdressers where
you paid into a similar kind of service
in those days planning or establish that
a hairdresser was a shock so we have
that through the courts as they
established for many decades
tattooists are defined by the
regulations we work through that they
are outside of actually any class so
they I can confirm to you they are a non
retail use yes you might argue that
they're appropriate to attempts to a
shopping area we don't disagree with
that but your policy in this space is we
should hang out for shops you prove in a
bit another retailer when a computer
shop by Katie couldn't have occupied
that and therefore get maintaining the
retail offer that's a start tonight
thank you Kevin
just first of all just to clarify one
particular point often follows move some
acting up to two years ago is now the
other side in the airport so it's now I
can come out there it's noticeable by
its absence to point them in I've
brought this forward because when you
look at these parade of shops it is a a
mishmash of different shops there's a
mode there's a disabled buddy shop
there's computer shop there's a
restaurant there was a hairdressers at
the other end which is stood vacant now
for probably a couple of years the
restaurant that you can see there for
example that stood I believe it was a
cat before but that stood empty for
quite some considerable time before the
restaurant was there so I think to find
another use for this shop would be would
be difficult it would find a difference
with regards to the use of the shop
there has been no complaints from any
residents as ward councillor and I'll
fast I'm aware that we know professional
couch counsel I certainly haven't
received income to the residents there
is sufficient parking out the front
there because it's quite a large lay-by
it starts with where their color roughly
is from the van right to the other end
in the shops others inland shops and
there is parking in the road adjacent
unlike the restaurant which would have
the considerable number of vehicles
parking I'm not sure how many tables
they've actually got in the restaurant
I'm not actually tried again but in the
tattoo parlor how many customers they're
going to have in any one time they need
two or three cars even had a big queue
at the door so it wasn't me Mike Stetz
isn't right
so at this stage I would rather see the
shot put to use to stand vacant because
I think it would stand bacon for
something sitting there time these type
of premises as a retail unit are very
very limited use and very limited
profitability and I would like to see it
suddenly be converted into a flat
because once that starts were to start
to lose the home for agency shops so
it's on that basis that I bring brought
it to committee and I would like to
propose that the County Commission is
granted
then I start to speak on this one but
the blade boy there because it doesn't
have any pop for the actual business so
I just I just wonder whether it would be
taking parking up from people if some
relations with India the OIT or computer
room our own was the bacon for between
yeah generally we don't know that we we
believe it was quite close but we don't
have on the application form submitted
it says that their computer shop
moontak so you don't know whether there
was a several weeks gap or several
months I was suggesting was probably in
the period of months or years I think
the policies for the retail Townsend's
released used to say the gap of two
years I'm not sure your policy currently
says that but it requires them to
demonstrate appear every time but it
tried to advertise it for the shop and
got no takers and then allows members to
consider new incentives but I'm afraid I
can't help you with the period between
the moons and the occupation or the time
service is this more used like that
there's been no demonstration that of
it could be in a manner of speaking
chairman yes what tends to happen is we
we sink a a survey or an appraisal by an
estate agent or somebody marketing the
site who demonstrate to us over so many
periods of time publications actually
give us a log sheet against the client
case that they've had this many
inquiries as many viewers etc discussion
of offers and then no takers and then
what people would get after a period of
time we see that what interest there was
with probably from some takeaways as
estate agents people like that you see
there was nobody looking for a real
title and then that allows us to
consider alternate channel uses what
happened in this case is the use
occurred our enforcement colleagues
chased it an application was made before
- not it so there's been no period where
they've been able to sample if there's a
big time interest and that gives us a
problem at least in recommending - but
it doesn't square with the policy you
have we were trying to retain these
shops as a retailer diversity to keep
the attraction and football on to the
pride in relation to the tournament you
use if this application was allowed to
go ahead that some future day if that
business moves does it affect the
[Music]
availability of that property for other
uses no it actually restricts it because
if this was granted planning permission
then opening payment permission for all
other uses for instance if it been
permitted as a shop then one shop could
file and another shop come in if it had
been permitted as a restaurant or a
takeaway that class will enable and
different cuisine operator - coming soon
generous users as a extends alone so you
would be granting permission for
tattooists and then another object that
came along what its uses the news agents
or something they might have to apply
that information back to a shop
we would need a name application to be
later the difficulty for the marketers
would be they they don't accountant
architects the testing shop they'd have
to get planning permission to something
else and then go to market without
mother's estate let alone a person into
the trade as recently trying to views
application of remedy it got plenty much
money earlier this year for take away
then I'll switch speakers counselor
that's a now on I think there's
retailers under pressure these days and
startup businesses and this is a might
say is a business it's supporting itself
perhaps we look at what's happening the
raj fisheries are four places of
clothing back on business as a moving
perhaps this we will look at this policy
is perhaps used to be a little bit more
open with it and they just accept the
fact if somebody else wanted to put
another business in the attack on food
we just have to go through the process
that's what we already signed the policy
the policy the officers need to make
that appropriate recommend a
professional recommendation how's the
Griffin Thank You children
two questions do we have any detail
about the length of the lease of the
property no Jim
and if the judgment went up against the
tattoo shop would they be required to
close at short notice
okay if if members were to follow the
recommendation and refused permission
tonight then
our enforcement colleagues would chase
this up now the planning authority even
though this doesn't have permission
acted before a government inspector
appear to have acted reasonably sorry
enforcement colleagues we advise the
applicant have been refused the
applicant will then have the option of
lodge an appeal within the next six
months that takes time they have to
consider their options find a consultant
self Anessa to the work and then they
submit so it would be reasonable for our
enforcement colleagues to give them
possibly six months to lodge being in
the appeal perhaps in the course of
doing so chases them every few weeks
over how you get nominated been any
movement or the applicants just riding
out the six months but once that period
for appeal has asked then enforcement
would have to chase this to say witness
to bring the right members made the
decision we've got to follow back
through and there were certain
enforcement notice it would be an
opportunity to appeal that but assuming
that the applicant has no appetite
probably because he hadn't appealed the
Planning Commission then at some stage
the enforcement notice would take effect
and then you start court proceedings etc
would you like to sum up and then we'll
go from
relation to its future if it was
granting permission as a tattoo is the
winning if that they was very painted
sometime in the future when it was
advertised it we're doing in be
advertised as a tattoo parlor and not a
retail outlet is that not limit its
potential future no Chairman what would
happen isn't because the text is outside
of news fallacies it's like you need to
itself okay so the only thing that's got
permission is to be attacked or anything
you read the class to say I won the
retail you can grant an admission for a
butcher's butcher style owns an estate
agent that fails characters as a
hairdresser they're all entitled uses
underclass they won a tattooist is alone
from that all you'd be granting
permission or effectively the uses of it
as a taxing power that been aisles all
the marketers to empathize in As I Lay
tattooist because I see everything's got
planet report business participating
tattooist my assumption would be that
they any sort of estate agent would seek
a new Planning Commission it to take
away retail or whatever and then go to
the market with that broader appeal
crystal ball but that I've seen that
happened before with something
the position or something like that it
doesn't even affect the ability they
design so you know if you grant planet
missions tonight it's only commissioned
with baby as they as a tattooist if
somebody else came in as a result of
people being violently sighting they
would need planet miss you wait for that
you see thank you thank you
I just want just so people can see the
just the size of the parking playability
dead with car park
this is what vehicle to the right the
car park almost goes towards that even
excellent as far as the shop on the
corner there is concerned that stood
empty now for some couple of years at
least being honest
if looking for business defined that are
far more attractive site then this
morning shop further on being a
permanent plot so I think it's very safe
to bet that if you can't let that out
after couple years nothing and that was
more shopping so really what I want to
do is propose that we cannot plantation
before this on the basis that's a clean
there for some time it's not post any
problem there isn't any issues we've
been talking and no complaints from
residents and I'd rather see back there
than it's empty or the right equipment
would you be happy for the officers
retrospectively to add standard
conditions to turn the approval
there are any standard conditioners that
you might be putting forward the only
one possibly chairman is that you say
that conversely you say that the moment
has to start within five years because
the time younger you just have you okay
that members in favor of the approval of
this change of uses football by concept
out please indicate those games thank
you
thank you